so what i have here are a few
definitions that will be useful for a
proof we're going to do that connects
the worlds of congruence of line
segments to the idea of them having the
same length so first of all there's this
idea of rigid transformations which
we've talked about in other videos but
just as a refresher these are
transformations that preserve distance
between points so for example if i have
points a
and b
a rigid transformation could be
something like a translation because
after i've translated them notice the
distance between the points is still the
same
it could be like that
it includes rotation let's say i rotate
it about point a is the center of
rotation
that still would not change
that still would not change my distance
between points a and b it could even be
things like taking the mirror image once
again that's not going to change the
distance between a and b what's not a
rigid transformation well one thing you
might imagine is dilating scaling it up
or down that is going to change the
distance so rigid transformation are any
transformations that preserve the
distance between points
now another idea is congruence
and
in the context of this video we're going
to be viewing the definition of
congruence as two figures are congruent
if and only if there exists a series of
rigid transformations which will map one
figure on to
the other you might see other
definitions of congruence in your life
but this is the rigid transformation
definition of congruence that we will
use and we're going to use these two
definitions to prove the following to
prove that saying two segments are
congruent is equivalent to saying that
they have the same length
so let me get some space here to do that
in so first let me prove that if
segment a b is congruent to segment cd
then
the length of segment a b which we'll
just denote as a b without the line over
it is equal to the length of segment cd
how do we do that
well the first thing to realize is if a
b
if
a
b
is congruent to c d
then
a b
can
be
mapped
onto
cd
with
rigid transformations
rigid
transformations that comes out of the
definition
of congruence
and then we could say
since
the
transformations
are
rigid
distance
is preserved
preserved
and so that would imply that the
distance between the points are going to
be the same
a b the distance between points a b or
the length of segment a b is equal to
the length of segment c d that might
almost seem too intuitive for you but
that's all we're talking about so now
let's see if we can prove the other way
let's see if we can prove that if the
length of segment a b is equal to the
length of segment cd
then
segment a b is congruent to segment
c d
and let me draw them right over here
just to so let's say i have segment a
b
right over there and i'll draw another
segment that has the same length so
maybe it looks something like this this
is obviously hand drawn
so then let's call this c
d
so in order to prove this i have to show
hey if i have two segments with the same
length that there's always a set of
rigid transformations that will map one
segment onto the other which means by
definition they are congruent so let me
just construct those transformations
so my first rigid transformation that i
could do is to translate
translate and i'll underline the name of
the transformation
segment a b
so
that
point a
is
on
top
of point c or a is mapped onto c and you
could see that there's always a
translation to do that it would be
doing that and of course we would
translate
b would end up like that and so after
this translation it's going to be a
right over there a is going to be there
and then b
is going to be
right over there
now the second step i would do
is then rotate
a b
about
a so a is the center of rotation so i'm
going to rotate it
so
that
point b lies
on
ray
c
d well what does this transformation do
well since point a is the center of
rotation a is going to stay mapped on
top of c from our first translation but
now b is rotated so it sits on top of
the ray that starts at c
and goes through d and keeps going
and where will b be on that ray well
since the distance between b and a is
the same as the distance between d and c
and a and c are the same point and now b
sits on that ray b will now sit right on
top of d
because
a b is equal to c d
b
will
be
mapped
onto
onto
d
and just like that we've shown that if
the segment lengths are equal there is
always a set of rigid transformations
that will map one segment onto the other
therefore since a and b have been mapped
onto c and d we know that a that segment
a b is congruent to segment c d
and we are done we have proven what we
set out to prove both ways